la france s'est engagée pour le respect
des valeurs humanistes de tolérance et
de respect de l'humanité à travers les
actions qu'elle conduit non seulement en
irak au sein de la coalition en syrie et
partout ailleurs sur le continent
africain comme en témoigne notre
engagement à la fois au mali ou en
république centrafricaine et partout il
y à des femmes des hommes qui sont
persécutés en raison de ce qu'ils sont
de ce que sont leurs appartenances
religieuses politiques ou leur
orientation sexuelle la france est là
pour rappeler les valeurs fondamentales
des droits de l'homme rappeler ce qu'est
le message multiséculaire que les
peuples du monde ont appris à aimer
d'elle pour reprendre l'expression de
françois mitterrand pour faire en sorte
aussi que partout où des femmes et des
hommes sont persécutés il y est un
refuge où la vie puisse se poursuivre
avec le bénéfice de la protection cette
protection que l'on doit toujours aux
réfugiés qui depuis 1793 inspire la
politique de la france
nous agissons en irak en syrie en
afrique
nous agissons résolument en europe et
nous agissons également dans notre pays
de manière à faire en sorte que notre
système d'asile et que notre politique
migratoire soit à la hauteur des enjeux
auxquels notre monde se trouvent
confrontés nous agissons d'abord en
europe et le premier ministre l'a
rappelé tout à l'heure avec force à
l'assemblée nationale la france n'a pas
attendu la crise migratoire qui se
déploie sous nos yeux depuis plusieurs
semaines avec cette dimension tragique
pour agir dès le 30 août 2014
à la demande du président de la
république je m'étais rendu il ya donc
de cela plus d'un an dans les
principales capitales européennes pour
tenter de faire partager à mes
homologues des pays de l'union
européenne un projet et des propositions
susceptible d'aspirer la politique de
l'union c'est à dire les propositions de
la commission en matière de politique
migratoire
quel était le constat est que
contenaient ces propositions d'abord
l'importance des flux migratoires
l'arrivée déjà en 2014 de près de 200
mille migrants qui avaient franchi les
frontières extérieures de l'union
européenne notamment en italie mais pas
seulement en italie certains déjà
franchissez les frontières extérieures
de l'union européenne en grèce
le constat qu'il y avait parmi ceux qui
venaient sur notre continent
des réfugiés qui relevait du statut de
réfugié en europe parce qu'ils étaient
persécutés dans leur propre pays mais
également des migrants qui avaient fui
la misère dans leur pays qu'ils venaient
pour beaucoup d'entre eux d'afrique de
l'ouest et qui cherchaient parce que les
passeurs les avait convaincus que cela
était possible
un avenir économique pour eux-mêmes et
pour leurs familles sur le territoire
européen et la première proposition qui
avait été formulée par la france était
celle de la nécessité urgente d'un
dialogue avec les pays de provenance
notamment les pays de la bande sahélo
saharienne de manière à ce que
l'immigration économique irrégulière
puissent être prévenues
plutôt que de devoir être constatée et
que nous puissions par la mise en place
de centres de maintien est de retour
éviter que ces familles que ces hommes
ces femmes ne se retrouve entre les
mains des passeurs et n'empruntent ce
voyage de la mort qui a conduit en 2014
près de 3000 femmes hommes enfants a
trouvé la mort en méditerranée
la deuxième proposition que formulé la
france avait fait l'objet d'une
discussion extrêmement animée mais en
même temps très riche avec l'italie
était que l'on supprime à l'opération
marenostrum pour lui substituer une
opération sous la maîtrise d'ouvragé de
frontex
parce que marc est lost room qu'avait
décidé les italiens seul avait eu pour
vertu
parce que c'était une opération
humanitaire digne et noble de sauver des
vies mais comme elle avait aussi incité
les pacers à mettre davantage de
migrants sur des embarcations de plus en
plus nombreuses et de plus en plus frêle
à la fin il y avait plus de sauvetage
mais il y avait aussi plus de morts et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
pensions qu'une opération conduite sous
la maîtrise d'ouvragé de frontex était
de nature à permettre un meilleur
contrôle des frontières extérieures de
l'union européenne et en même temps
d'armer l'union européenne dans un
combat qui devait être menée absolument
celui de la lutte contre les filières de
passeurs
c'est à dire contre les organisations
internationales du crime qui sont de
véritables filières de la traite des
êtres humains
travailler avec les pays de provenance
substituer à l'opération marenostrum une
opération sous maîtrise d'ouvragé de
l'union européenne c'est-à-dire de
frontex lutter contre les filières de
l'immigration irrégulière sauver des
vies en même temps que l'on assurait la
protection de nos frontières extérieures
c'était l'ambition que proposait la
france à nos autres pays de l'union
européenne nous pensions aussi que dès
lors que les flux était important est
que cinq pays seulement sur 28 de
l'union européenne a accueilli 75 % de
la demande d'asile qui s'exprimait en
europe nous estimions qu'il était normal
que émergent les fondements d'une
politique européenne de l'asile corps et
permet une répartition plus équitable
des demandeurs d'asile entre les
différents pays de l'union européenne
de telle sorte à ce que l'europe soit à
la hauteur de sa réputation et qu'elle
puisse conformément aux valeurs des
pères fondateurs affirmé des valeurs que
la france avait longtemps portée et qui
devait conduire l'europe toute entière
par delà les différences qui existait
entre ces nations à être à la hauteur
des drames humanitaires que nous
sentions se profiler nous pensions aussi
qu'il était important et c'était notre
quatrième proposition que au moment du
franchissement des frontières
extérieures de l'union européenne sous
maîtrise d'ouvragé de la commission avec
la contribution éventuelle du hr et de
frontex
il y ait un dispositif organisé
permettant de distinguer les réfugiés
des migrants économiques irrégulier de
manière à procéder à l'enregistrement de
tous de pouvoir accueillir dès leur
arrivée sur le territoire de l'union
ce qui relevait de l'asile en europe
pour éviter cette errance et ce nouvel
exode sur les routes européennes et que
frontex puisse parce qu'il y aurait eu
préalablement des accords de retour avec
les pays de la zone sahélo-saharienne
organiser le retour l'éloignement dans
des conditions humaines des migrants qui
relevait de l'immigration économique
irrégulière
ces propositions ont été formulées sans
trêve ni pause par la france au cours
des derniers mois jusqu'à ce que l'union
européenne après que la france avait
mutualiser ses propositions avec
l'allemagne décide de reprendre un
certain nombre d'entre elles pour les
soumettre à la délibération du conseil
justice et affaires intérieures et du
conseil européens au cours des derniers
mois nous avons tout fait pour que le
dispositif de solidarité a sorti des
conditions de responsabilité que je
viens d'indiquer soient mises en oeuvre
nous sommes réjouis que quarante mille
réfugiés puissent être réparti entre les
28 pays de l'union européenne sur une
base volontaire et le conseil justice et
affaires intérieures de lundi a
définitivement acté ce principe et nous
avons avec l'allemagne compte tenu de
l'ampleur de la crise migratoire indiqué
que nous étions disposés à accueillir
120 mille réfugiés supplémentaires au
titre du processus de relocalisation
compte tenu de l'ampleur de la crise et
de la nécessité face à cette crise
d'être à la hauteur du défi
en remplissant nos obligations
politiques et morales bien entendu
l'importance du flux de réfugiés
résultant de l'activité intense des
passeurs mais aussi de la dégradation de
la situation internationale et de la
situation politique à la fois
libye et en syrie cette augmentation du
flux a conduit le gouvernement allemand
a décidé dimanche soir de rétablir des
contrôles à la frontière sans pour
autant fermer sa frontière avec
l'autriche
de telle sorte à ce que soit garantie la
bonne application des règles qui
régissent l'union européenne et
notamment des règles de dublin et de
schengen parce qu'il ne peut pas y avoir
de solidarité
s'il n'ya pas le respect des règles qui
lie les pays de l'union européenne les
uns aux autres j'avais d'ailleurs et
cela avait été critiquée pris des
dispositions similaires il ya de cela
trois mois lorsque nous avions constaté
à la frontière franco-italienne un
afflux de réfugiés qui nécessitait
compris ses mesures de régulation et de
prudence et le premier ministre a
indiqué tout à l'heure que si nous
devions être amené dans des
circonstances identiques à celles que
nous avons déjà vécu à procéder aux
mêmes dispositions
nous les mettrons en oeuvre et je dois
vous indiquer par souci de transparence
que toute disposition dans les services
qui relève du ministère de l'intérieur
sont d'ores et déjà prises pour le cas
où nous devrions ce ce que nous ne
souhaitons pas faire face à une
situation de cette nature
donc la france a été constamment à
l'action en europe elle est encore
aujourd'hui et elle est autour d'une
doctrine claire que le premier ministre
a rappelé tout à l'heure à l'assemblée
nationale et qui se décline en trois
principes
le premier c'est la réaffirmation par la
france et par la france au sein de
l'union européenne de la non
négociabilité du statut de réfugié plein
1 et entier comme les principes de la
république et qui doit pour tous ceux
qui sont en besoin de protection
s'appliquer sur le territoire européen
d'où que ces réfugiés viennent quelle
que soit leur religion quelles que
soient leurs orientations politiques dès
lors bien entendu
qui ne sont pas liées à ces groupes
abject qui en syrie sem la barbarie et
la haine
et comme le premier mis je veux dire ici
à la tribune du sénat que il y a comme
un manquement un abaissement aux
principes du droit d'asile que de
considérer que l'on pourra accueillir
les uns et les autres
les chrétiens et pas les représentants
des autres minorités
car si nous faisons cela nous dérange
riom au principe de l'asile et pour
m'être entretenu avec les représentants
des cultes et notamment avec les
représentants de l'épiscopat je sais que
sur ces valeurs universelles et ses
principes il y a par delà la sphère
publique et politique un large consensus
entre tous ceux qui sont soucieux de
voir les principes de l'humanité de la
civilisation humaine
les principes humanistes s'appliquer
dans leur entièreté est ici à la tribune
du sénat
je voulais rappeler la nécessité de ne
jamais oublier ses principes
dès lors que l'essentiel est en jeu
c'est à dire l'avenir de l'humanité
nous avons agi en europe nous avons agi
dans cet équilibre responsabilité
humanité nous avons aussi et vous le
savez mieux que quiconque puisque vous
avez largement participé à ces débats
agit en france car il ne s'agit pas
simplement d'être dans la générosité
on ne veut pas que se contenter
simplement d'affirmer des principes face
à une crise grave
il faut être en situation lorsque les
principes sont énoncées de faire face et
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
doctrine de la france n'a jamais changé
en europe
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
n'avons jamais déroger à cet équilibre
entre humanité responsabilités et
fermeté et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons voulu mettre au niveau
notre système d'asile en france qu'avons
nous fait au terme des travaux qui ont
été conduits par à la fois valérie
létard et jean louis touraine c'est à
dire à la fois par l'assemblée nationale
et le sénat par la majorité l'opposition
ou par jeanine dubié arnaud richard à
l'assemblée nationale
qu'avons nous fait au terme des
amendements et des réflexions qui ont
été conduites par les rapporteurs du
texte relatif à l'asile aussi bien à
l'assemblée nationale je veux saluer le
travail de sandrine mazetier du
président de la commission des lois jean
jacques urvoas que ici au sénat et je
veux saluer le travail du président
philippe bas et du rapporteur françois
noël buffet nous l'avons fait ensemble
même s'il ya eu des débats nous avons
voulu d'abord mettre notre système
d'asile en conformité avec les
directives européennes aux meilleurs
standards européens
cela nous a conduits à réduire de 24 à 9
mois la durée de traitement des dossiers
des demandeurs d'asile comment l'avons
nous fait non pas en le décrétant mais
en donnant des moyens significatifs à
l'eau froid plusieurs dizaines d'emplois
ont été créés 50 très exactement
d'autres le seront au terme des
décisions que nous avons pris de nous
inscrire dans la relocalisation 196 très
exactement au sein de l'offre à 2 lo fi
et des services préfectoraux dans le
cadre de la mise en oeuvre du guichet
unique dans les prochains mois nous
avons décidé aussi de mettre au niveau
notre dispositif d'accueil des
demandeurs d'asile en créant treize
mille places en cada auxquels s'ajoutent
les 5000 annoncé par le premier mis cet
après midi à l'assemblée nationale
de manière à ce que nous puissions faire
face à nos obligations dans le cadre du
processus européen de solidarité de
relocalisation et de réinstallation ce
qui portera l'effort de ce gouvernement
en matière de mise à niveau des
conditions d'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile à dix-huit mille cinq cents
places en cada d'ici à la fin du
quinquennat
là où il en avait été créée 2000 au
cours de la précédente législature
nous avons également décidé de faire en
sorte que les droits des demandeurs
d'asile devant les instances où leurs
dossiers sont examinés puisse être
davantage reconnus c'est ainsi que nous
avons par exemple dans la loi prévue le
caractère suspensif des démarches devant
le juge dans le cadre de procédures
accélérées ou autorisée
les demandeurs d'asile à être
accompagnés de leurs conseils lorsqu'ils
engagent des démarches à l'ofpra
quel est le résultat de cette loi parce
que les moyens ont été alloués avant que
la loi ne soit votée
d'abord nous avons réussi cette année a
augmenté de 20% le nombre de dossiers
traités et par là même à raccourcir
d'autant de 20%
la durée des délais des dossiers des
demandeurs d'asile ce qui permet un
traitement à la fois plus humain plus
rapide une prise en compte plus
exigeante de ce qu'est la difficulté
auquel les demandeurs d'asile sont
confrontés et en même temps le retour à
la frontière dans des conditions plus
simple humainement et administrativement
de ceux qui sont déboutés du droit
d'asile
je me souviens que nous avons eu ce
débat lorsque la loi zyl a été votée et
je veux là aussi réaffirmé clairement
les principes devant le sénat si nous
voulons pouvoir accueillir tous ceux qui
relèvent du statut de réfugié en europe
et en france il y à une condition de
cette soutenabilité c'est que ce qui ne
relève pas de l'asile parce qu'ils
entendront ils en ont été déboutés après
des procédures ou leurs droits ont été
reconnus après avoir été confortés
doivent pouvoir dans des conditions
humaines être reconduite à la frontière
sinon il n'y a pas de soutenabilité de
l'asile en france et raccourcir les
délais c'est permettre une reconduite
dans des conditions plus aisé de ceux
qui sont déboutés du droit d'asile alors
j'entends parfois un certain nombre de
parlementaires ou de responsables
politiques indiqué que nous ne
reconduisons que 10 à 17% des déboutés
du droit d'asile et que les autres
restent en france au cours de l'année
qui vient de s'écouler
le nombre de ceux qui déboutés du droit
d'asile ont fait l'objet d'un
éloignement dans des conditions
particulièrement méticuleuse par les
services qui veille aussi lorsqu'il ya
la reconduite à ce que les principes
d'humanité soit respectée
les déboutés reconduit ont augmenté de
près de 20% au cours de l'année qui
vient de s'écouler et nous entendons
poursuivre à la faveur de cette loi
ces efforts parce que sinon il n'y aura
pas de soutenabilité de ce que nous
faisons je dois dire aussi qu'il en est
de même pour que ceux qui ne sont pas
déboutés du droit d'asile et qui relève
de l'immigration irrégulière doivent
aussi pouvoir être reconduit et là aussi
je donnerai au moment des échanges après
la discussion générale les chiffre
extrêmement précis mais pour que vous
ayez un ordre de grandeur
lorsqu'il s'agit des reconduites forcées
c'est à dire celles qui sont les plus
difficiles à mettre en oeuvre
je ne parle pas des retours spontanés
que l'on a par le passé comptabilisés
dans les retours
si je ne tient compte que des retours
forcés ils ont augmenté au cours de
l'année précédente
de plus de 13% et sur la période 2012
ils sont passés de 13 milles à 16000
parce que là aussi il n'y a pas de
compatibilité entre la volonté de
pouvoir accueillir tous ceux qui doivent
l'être est une sorte de manquements dans
la fermeté qui doit s'appliquer à ceux
qui ne peuvent pas être accueillis sur
le territoire national il n'y a pas
d'humanité là où il n'y a pas de
responsabilité et il n'y a pas
d'humanité là aussi où il n'y a pas
d'application ferme des principes du
droit voté par la représentation
nationale lorsqu'il s'agit de ces
questions essentielles remise en place
du système d'asile avec les résultats
que je viens de vous indiquer allocation
de moyen supplémentaire renforcement
aussi des moyens des forces de l'ordre
pourquoi parce qu'il n'y a pas de
possibilité de lutter contre
l'immigration irrégulière et contre les
filières de passeurs
si nous ne remettons pas à niveau notre
dispositif policier pour faire face et
de ce point de vue là la suppression de
15 unités de forces mobiles entre 2007
et 2012 à dans le contexte que nous
connaissons quelques effets collatéraux
quand il faut à la fois par la
mobilisation des unités de forces
mobiles mettre en oeuvre le plan
vigipirate dans un contexte de risques
terroristes élevés procédé à la
sécurisation des frontières et
d'infrastructures de transport lourde à
la fois à calais et à vintimille assurée
par ailleurs la présence dans des
quartiers sensibles où la présence d'une
unité de forces mobiles est un des
éléments de diminution de la délinquance
et bien lorsqu'on a perdu 15 unités de
forces mobiles
cela se sent dans les tensions qui
pèsent sur le ministère de l'intérieur
qui doit en toutes circonstances être en
situation de remplir ses missions
régaliennes c'est la raison pour
laquelle le premier ministre lorsqu'il
était ministre de l'intérieur et
aujourd'hui comme premier ministre a
décidé malgré la contrainte budgétaire
de réhausser les moyens des services qui
dépendent du ministère de l'intérieur et
qui ont pour mission d'assurer la lutte
contre l'immigration irrégulière 500
policiers et gendarmes de plus chaque
année 1500 affectée à la lutte contre le
terrorisme dans le cadre du plan de
lutte quantité orist décidé au mois de
janvier est le premier ministre a
indiqué que face à l'ampleur du
phénomène migratoire
c'était 900 policiers et gendarmes
supplémentaires qui seraient affectés
aux forces de sécurité dans les deux ans
qui viennent de manière à leur permettre
de remplir les missions qui sont les
leurs en matière de contrôle des
frontières et en matière de
démantèlement des filières de
l'immigration irrégulière
mais sans attendre cette remise à niveau
calé en matière de lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière et de
démantèlement des filières de
l'immigration irrégulière quelles sont
les résultats depuis le début de l'année
ce sont 177 filière représentant 3300
personnes qui ont été démantelés ces
trois mille trois cents personnes ont
été interpellées pour une grande partie
d'entre elles judiciariser elle
constitue cette horde de délinquants qui
dans les filières de la traite des êtres
humains pousse vers la mort des hommes
des femmes en situation de vulnérabilité
le nombre de d'acteurs de l'immigration
irrégulière qui ont été maîtrisés depuis
2014 a augmenté
2 25% et nous avions le même résultat
entre 2014 et 2015 sur la seule ville de
calais gens parlent devant la sénatrice
natacha bouchart ses vins filières de
l'immigration irrégulière qui ont été
démantelés depuis le début de l'année
représentant à peu près 800 acteurs et
nous allons poursuivre cette action
résolument sans trêve ni pause parce que
nous devons combattre nationalement et
au plan européen
ces filières de l'immigration
irrégulière qui sont encore une fois de
véritables filières de la traite des
êtres humains
voilà ce que nous avons fait au plan
national
européen je voudrais dire maintenant
quelques mots sur ce qu'il reste à faire
il y a devant nous la loi sur le séjour
cette loi sur le séjour donne d'autres
outils au gouvernement pour pouvoir
procéder à l'éloignement dans des
conditions humaines de ceux qui doivent
l'être je pense à la clarification de la
compétence entre le juge administratif
et le juge judiciaire
je pense également aux outils dont nous
nous dotons pour faire en sorte que ceux
qui au moment de l'enregistrement ne
veulent pas se conformer aux règles qui
sont celles de l'union européenne
puissent se voir convaincu de le faire
par des processus de judiciarisation qui
ont leur efficacité et je suis convaincu
que l'articulation entre la loisil et la
loi sur le séjour en cours de discussion
devant le parlement qui viendra devant
le sénat dans les prochaines semaines
permettra d'aboutir à un vrai résultat
mais il reste aussi à quelques jours du
conseil j'aille d'autres chantiers à
concrétiser
et là aussi le premier ministre a eu
l'occasion devant l'assemblée nationale
tout à l'heure d'exprimer quelles sont
les priorités de la france et je les
résume en quelques mots d'abord faire en
sorte que les hotspots dont le principe
a été acté à l'occasion du conseil de
lundi dernier soit mise en oeuvre
effectivement les prochains jours sous
maîtrise d'ouvragé de l'union européenne
qu'ils puissent faire l'objet d'une mise
en oeuvre notamment grèce dans les
meilleurs délais pour que le processus
de relocalisation puisse être enclenchée
et que la détresse des migrants relevant
du statut de réfugiés puissent être
soulagé dans les meilleurs délais et
pour cela nous avons besoin d'un
engagement fort de la commission
européenne et d'un engagement rapide dès
lors que le principe a été acté lundi
dernier deuxièmement il est important
que la haute représentante pour l'union
européenne
madame aubry ni en charge de la
négociation des conventions de retour
avec les pays de provenance et de la
mise en place des centres de maintien et
de retour puisse rapidement conclure les
conventions qui doivent être passés avec
les pays de provenance de manière à ce
que nous ayons une efficacité du
dispositif global parce que si ce qui
arrive dans les hot spots et qui ne sont
pas susceptibles de bénéficier du statut
de réfugié ne sont pas reconduits
éloignés vers leurs pays de provenance
il n'y aura pas d'efficacité de ce que
nous faisons au plan européen donc la
deuxième exigence de la france et une
rapidité dans la mise en oeuvre de cette
disposition sous l'impulsion de la haute
représentante
troisièmement nous souhaitons que les
niveaux du hcr les niveaux de
contribution du hr au centre de réfugiés
qui sont en turquie en jordanie au liban
soirée hausse s'est rapidement de
manière à ce qu'il n'y ait pas de
nouveaux mouvements de population qui
aggrave encore la crise migratoire et
que nous puissions avoir le temps de
mettre en oeuvre dans des conditions
maîtriser le processus de relocalisation
et la france a indiqué cette
disponibilité pour que un dispositif
conventionnel soit élaboré et signé avec
la serbie permettant à la serbie de nous
aider à la mise en place de ce processus
de maîtrise des flux migratoires
puisqu'elle a dit sa disponibilité pour
m chez elle des centres
intermédiaire permettant de garder
pendant quelques semaines en serbie des
migrants relevant du statut de réfugié
curé évocation être accueillis en europe
il faut aussi c'est notre demande
augmenter les moyens de frontex pour
assurer la bonne maîtrise des frontières
extérieures de l'union européenne et
pour ce qui concerne le processus de
relocalisation nous avons là aussi
clairement dit que l'europe ne peut pas
être une europe à la carte que la
solidarité ne peut pas concerner les un
sens concerné les autres et que l'europe
faillirait si l'ensemble des pays qui la
constituent ne montrez pas leurs
capacités ensemble dans la solidarité
affaire a fonctionné un principe
humanitaire qui renvoie aux valeurs les
plus éminentes que les pères fondateurs
de l'union européenne
on plaçait comme une espérance au coeur
des institutions de l'europe
je voudrais conclure mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames et
messieurs les ministres
en deux mots d'abord le débat qui nous
rassemble est un débat sur lequel il
doit y avoir beaucoup de rigueur parce
qu'il arrive que sur ce sujet qui n'est
pas sans être un sujet de débats
politiques et parfois même de débat
électoral beaucoup d'approximations
laisse certains acteurs politiques à
penser qu'il pourrait faire beaucoup de
voix
j'ai vu par exemple certains principes
convoqué récemment de manière étrange je
pense par exemple je le dis sans esprit
de polémique mais plutôt avec l'esprit
juridique
le principe de réfugiés de guerre c'est
intéressant le principe de réfugiés de
gaia pas de raison de ne pas accepter
qu'ils puissent être remis sur le métier
et considérant qu' il y avait en france
deux dispositifs le droit d'asile qui
est un et indivisible et qui ne
distingue pas les réfugiés selon la
nature des drames auxquels ils sont
confrontés
et puis une protection dite subsidiaire
qui permet à ceux qui sont victimes de
la guerre dans leur pays qui ne relèvent
pas de l'asile parce qu'ils ne sont pas
persécutés de pouvoir bénéficier d'une
protection en france il nous paraissait
que ces deux dispositifs couvrait à eux
seuls parfaitement la totalité du champ
des possibles
elles des hommes des femmes en situation
de vulnérabilité peuvent être confrontés
mais on m'a expliqué à ce moment là que
le statut de réfugié de guerre trouver
sa place dans une directive de 2001
pouvait lire la directive de 2001 il n'y
a pas à aucun moment aucun alinéa vous
trouverez le concept de réfugiés de
guerre ce que vous trouverez dans la
directive de 2001 c'est un concept qui
est la protection transitoire qui est
l'équivalent au plan européen de ce
qu'est la protection subsidiaire donc le
statut de réfugié de guerre n'est pas
une mauvaise propositions c'est une
proposition sans objet puisque ce qui
pourrait relever du statut de réfugié de
guerre en europe peuvent bénéficier
exactement dans les mêmes conditions de
ce qu'on appelle la protection
subsidiaire en france c'est donc une
proposition qui ne me choque pas mais
qui a eu ni utile ni inutilité absolue
puisqu'elle existe déjà en droit
français
il n'est donc jamais mauvais de faire
des propositions sur ce qui existe déjà
et depuis longtemps
c'est d'ailleurs la même meilleure
manière de réussir un consensus que de
proposer ce qui existe déjà depuis
longtemps et que personne ne conteste
jamais puisque on s'y est accoutumé ce
qui est plus étrange surtout quand c'est
par le truchement de hauts responsables
politiques qui ont exercé les
responsabilités que j'exerce
actuellement c'est de faire apparaître
comme totalement nouveau ce qui existe
depuis très longtemps et que chacun
connaît qui s'intéressent à ces sujets
je pourrais prendre un autre exemple qui
est celui de schengen propose un
schengen 2 pourquoi pas moi même j'ai
souvent ressenti la nécessité de
procéder à une évolution de schengen
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme par
exemple faire en sorte que dans le cas
du code schengen actuelle on puisse
procéder à des contrôles coordonnée et
simultanée aux frontières de l'union
européenne pour être plus efficace dans
la lutte contre le terrorisme ne me
paraît pas absurde dans le cadre de
schengen parce que les règles
l'autorisent procéder à des contrôles
aux frontières à l'instar de ce que font
les allemands de ce que j'ai fait
il ya de cela quelques mois à la
frontière franco italienne n'est pas
choquant et donc je me suis posé la
question de savoir ce qui était schengen
2 alors il est plusieurs déclarations
intéressantes qui expliquait ce qui
était une gaine de une première qui
expliquait que schengen 2 c'était
schengen un don on respecterait les
règles
bon c'est pas un sujet sur lequel on
peut manifester de désaccord la non plus
entre nous il est rare que des ensembles
aussi complexe que l'union européenne se
dote de règles pour ne pas vouloir les
respecter sans que si schengen 2c
schengen 1 avec les mêmes règles dont on
respecterait les principes
je pense que nous pouvons à l'exception
de 1 ou 2 sénateurs que je vois en eau
de l'hémicycle tombés d'accord pour que
nous puissions je me les rend semble sur
ce point ensuite j'ai entendu que
schengen 2 c'était des contrôles aux
frontières extérieures de l'union
européenne et qu'il fallait pouvoir
mettre en place ses frontières pour
éviter que le franchissent les
frontières extérieures de l'union
européenne ce qui ne relève pas du
statut de réfugié en europe
mais lorsque dans le cadre des règles de
schengen 1
les pays de l'union européenne propose
la mise en place de hotspots en italie
et en grèce
que fait-on si ce n'est d'assurer la
protection des frontières extérieures de
l'union européenne en mettant en place
des dispositifs qui permettent de
distinguer les réfugiés de ceux qui ne
le sont pas par conséquent si schengen
de consiste à faire ce que nous faisons
déjà dans schengen 1 avec les pays de
l'union européenne
là non plus je n'ai pas vraiment de
désaccord et puis une troisième
proposition que j'ai vu poindre dans le
figaro la semaine dernière c'est
schengen deux cd frontières à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne mais
simplement pour ceux qui ne sont pas
européens
là c'est plus compliqué pour avoir un
accord parce que si nous mettons en
place des frontières intérieures à
l'union européenne c'est à dire entre
nos pays
outre le fait qu'il faudra déployer des
moyens considérables pour les restaurer
je voudrais que l'on m'explique à partir
de quels critères
et selon lequel quelles modalités
lorsque ces france frontières seront
franchies on distinguera les européens
des autres et comment on pourra les
distinguer sans
les interpeller tous sans les bloquer
tous à la frontière je le connais malgré
les progrès faits par nos meilleurs
industrie morpho safran les autres aucun
dispositif qui permette spontanément par
les truchements et les progrès de la
technologie de distinguer aux frontières
spontanément ceux qui sont aux européens
de ceux qui ne le sont pas et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je pense que si la
seule modification de schengen c'est la
mise en place de ce dispositif
il faudra discuter l'otan dans cet
hémicycle et dans d'autres et notamment
parlement européen pour arriver à
trouver un accord qui permette de mettre
en oeuvre un tel dispositif
sans remettre en cause totalement le
fonctionnement de l'union européenne y
compris le fonctionnement du marché
intérieur
voilà mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs ce que je souhaitais vous dire
j'espère que le débat que nous aurons ce
soir nous permettra de cheminer ensemble
j'ai grand espoir que ce soit le cas
mais une petite lucidité me conduit
aussi à penser que cela pourrait ne pas
être atteint dès ce soir c'est la raison
pour laquelle je suis tout à fait prêt à
revenir la semaine prochaine